okay Pierre what helped your brands here
still here Chris waters here also here
yeah and we're gonna talk about we're
gonna talk more come at ten cuz you
played it last week
well combat X X sorry about ten even
though the last one was nine ten
thousand eleven two thousand eleven but
yeah let's talk about I played some last
week yeah I was no I want to know I've
got a list of all the characters that
are announced and I want to basically
just get real pissy about why Barack is
not a lot of yeah but first of all it's
just first of all you tell me what you
think about royal complex so I'm like a
Street Fighter player over time for most
I used to play Mortal Kombat back in the
day and I've I sampled the the latest
ones over the past few years the more
Kombat X definitely has a much better
flow to it I would characterize past
games as being very stiff hmm this still
has a bit of that but it's it's much
easier to sort of create a combo of your
own and kind of feel like you're you've
got momentum you know and you're not
just a punch and then back to your
stance and then a Carrick how're you
finding that is it three the de call
them stances the three different
variation variations you have is that
stuff working well so essentially each
character's variation comes with
different moves that are available to
them sometimes that means that they have
access to a weapon that'll open up some
moves and and I think that generally
there's sort of a paradigm that's that's
it goes across all characters like one
maybe have a little bit more speed one
may hit a little bit harder but it's not
like a blanket like this is the fast
version versus the strong version versus
then whatever right and all the
fatalities are across all three of those
yes yes there are no special fatalities
how you enjoying the fatalities they're
they're pretty gruesome man I don't know
that I enjoy all of them like it's it's
definitely shocking to see some of this
stuff and I think that's where you get
the enjoyment is because the surprise of
like well they really thought about how
to divide your body apart take out real
creative Jesus yeah like how are at what
percentage of personnel we're gonna get
there should we get this year's no we're
gonna go get one like this just makes
you scream
happening to you as you do it as you
watch it but yeah
I could do without them honestly no I
think that I think I mean oh no they are
just they are that Devorah over the top
that's actually kind of a throwback one
right there I'm not saying that that
it's too much I'm just saying that I
don't need them to enjoy this game like
a good fighting game to me is not about
it protracted cutscene where I just
remember a person yeah but it's a big
Mortal Kombat thing right it's been for
a long shot that one's really good fun
just go on YouTube watch didn't we watch
like a supercut two weeks ago of all oh
my god yeah yeah like a three-hour one
going or something yeah of like every
Mortal Kombat fits out of the ever these
are these are pretty great that Conan's
skit where he was playing with Rob
Gronkowski and Marshawn Lynch before the
Super Bowl and Marshawn Lynch it's like
toughest dude and it felt like beating
mode running back just one of them
happens and he's like oh no dude um he's
like I'm done I gotta get out of here
how are the brutalities because they did
they work so they're different now yeah
there's something that's more brutal
than that they're not like the old ones
were like the old ones is like okay
you're gonna do a crazy long combo and
then they're gonna explode into giblets
right now it's kind of like there are
like multiple brutalities it's not just
one there are like limiting factors or
like things you have to do to make them
happen like in the combo yeah yeah I can
the facets of around you have to fulfill
certain criteria and I believe it's
different for every character and then
only then once you've done that are you
allowed to execute the brutality would
it be like get two uppercuts or like I
think it's more free more comical than
that headpiece come on might be like one
part of it oh really
do we have to go out of your way to yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna be interesting to
see because I like it's one of those
things that they they've said themselves
they want it to be like arcade again
where they want people to figure it out
and then people kind of like
word-of-mouth like hey that's how you do
the brutality like I think like Quan Chi
right like he has like a submariner
thing where it does a bunch of portals
and I don't know exactly how they did it
on the stream but it was like they the
they're meta criteria with him doing
enough portals and the last portal that
he did to end the round like teleported
the guy into a
a portal and then he's standing there
like with his arms crossed and then all
of the giblets just rain on him
Oh brutality right there that's a
brutality right there too nasty yeah
right yeah that's pretty Oh late a
little bug inside of it the fatality is
almost look better like these are just
kind of okay that's pretty ROG you know
interesting is the x-ray moves that you
pull off the middle of a fight when you
once your medial your meter fills up
making hit those are like more gruesome
in a way than a lot of the fatalities
because it's like okay your vertebra is
just your back is snapped in half I know
your jaw has been disconnected and now
your skull has been imploded now just
get right up but you just get right up
and you're fine then ain't no thing
nether realms been streaming a bunch of
this right yeah they do like everyone
like once a week maybe once every two
weeks something like that yeah they've
been showing off characters and one I'm
dripping at characters well let's get to
the characters let's go through every
single character that's been announced
for Mortal Kombat X and I want to hear
your guy's opinion on the first of all
favorite character Chris waters scorpion
nice
Mortal Kombat was banned in my household
I was always terrible at it I never got
good at it so it's just like I'll watch
it but my parents never brought us games
but for some reason like mom was at a
time when weekend I mean dad brought us
Santa and he was like what's that game
you guys are talking about well I call
him we'll come back to for like the
Amiga and he was like all right let's
buy it don't tell your mom except when
you got fatalities not getting me to
like swap disks to see them because it
was on like three days Wow terrible okay
Peter favorite Mortal Kombat hero
writing okay wait Ravens are riding from
Metal Gear Solid don't work that's
spelled the same as the other one okay
hey either smoker cabal probably me
there are you know about you Danny
any good yeah Wow Sub Zero so boring
Baraka [ __ ] alright confirmed characters
Cassie cage she's new she's the daughter
of Johnny Antonia all right fair enough
and devorah Buckley bug thing right okay
that was announced a lot ago that bug
thing
they're all they're all weird this firm
AK the like green thing
yeah he's new no he's no no no no I mean
these are new he's orange ninja so it
didn't look as thing before though who's
Aaron black he's like a fictional
character that they haven't their comic
opens the cowboy the gunslinger Greg's
pretty cool he kind of reminds me of a
Deathstroke though he looks real cool
like I would imagine that that is the
gunslinger from The Dark Tower Stephen
King's Dark Tower right seriously it
looks like I just kind of when I saw
Aaron black I was like that's projected
when there's just like regular dude
names in the middle of this raw scorpion
sub-zero Johnny Stevenson yeah no bell d
double ro n though you never stumble ro
M yeah you say that but then there's
also like predator yet the oppressors in
this game l see predator I'm Jason Jason
Voorhees right okay yeah god that's
weird
at Farrah tor which is the big guy in
the small with the little girl on top
Freddy Krueger kind yes she's got like a
mini Baraka no give me that I'm all
about that Baraka and Goro's in a big or
like a P or the bonus yeah pre-order and
you'll see I think I think I don't know
I know for sure pre-order okay thank you
could be wrong we'll see when is a
pre-order bonus DLC at Jackie is a new
one I don't know Jackie is it's a Max's
daughter Jack is it actually that's his
daughter
yes yeah also how long Jacqueline Briggs
she does not emit alarm she has Jackie
does she go gotcha it's Susan isn't it
smell differently it's JC q UI she's
name you're right no sir yeah just
Jackie yeah I've already got one John
Melanie you know Jackie from two ends in
her name alarm she has like aren't like
attachments like like kind of like robot
like like daughter like like father like
daughter go true at Johnny Cage of
course is back old man cave back Jax
himself forgot about that I don't know
if he's been confirmed yes apparently
they've only shown him as like the his
like possessed form he's not he's not in
character's life okay right now so my
there's like the worry that Vince Lassa
he's definitely in the stories all right
yeah okay no yup coming back
can she not confirmed yet in the story
oh really oh yeah katanas back yep I'm
guessing million is - yeah million is -
yeah a couple cans a new one right she's
that like kind of Voodoo dude or like
God thing yeah I don't know his
background and Sarah follows the car
jumping but yes total Kanye's new come
gin new character
yes descendent of Kung Lao it's just
bored with combos babies this way yes
that's what it's about it's about the
children it's like the next generation
is it the babe ality somebody may know
it all comes full circle
hey maybe are they due to help me about
of these okay I haven't seen anything
like that Adam an ADIZ they haven't
talked about friendships I'm sure that
if they're really gonna stick to this
whole like you have to discover what's
in the game yeah I'm sure there would be
and I'm not I wouldn't be surprised if
there is another allottee blt dlc dlc
Kong Lau is back yes
Liu Kang really confirmed last week yes
which always seemed dumped me because
he's kind of like the ryu of mortal
kombat but apparently some people think
he shouldn't be in the game cuz I guess
like based on the story he might be dead
yeah face so based on the story yeah
yeah the mortal compound yeah you got a
cannon like jade is dead jade is dead
and she's on the game she's like good
katanas kind of got a variation like if
you have to bring the bad girl this is
important I wrote up it like a little
thing based on the first chapter in this
game and I was like there's something I
don't understand it could we're like oh
my god how do you have a job and you
don't know that this X event happened at
the end of Mortal Kombat 9 oh my god
sorry question how does he yell that's
what I'm not sure I'm glad new cogs in
it because otherwise like how he's the
only person in video games you can go
like you still got it working out at the
gym at Quan Chi's back yep Ryden
just keep going just keep going this
reptile is everyone's favorite variation
are ninjas is the amphibian this time
yeah remember that time they had the
reptile just be a dude are you getting
that is angrier what like that's a real
thing yes looks more like
little he was just wearing his ninja
[ __ ] then when he pulled off his mask he
was like doctor it's like a room actual
reptile yeah I know that
yeah but then in another one he was like
it - I'd like a dude like hey mr. d no
no not even one yeah you look like a
ninja like like their typical name daddy
is green okay we'd rather say it was
totally not a Reza Reza I'm a dude now
Oh
scorpions back of course ha ha yeah
Chinook his back is out of some sort of
helicopter no he's one of the bad guys
he's he's kind of got that bad guy
really Kotaro yeah I guess so they told
me on my article anyway story trailer
kind of seems like the person you're
after but who knows this Johnny Cage the
Scorpion has so many blades back or she
back she playable yes okay
sub-zero yep at Takeda Takeshi Takeda
Takeshi Takeda hopefully I'm saying that
right never heard of us and then we also
have Tanya and tremor which are 90 days
DLC as well a separate character Tom
yeah Tanya's friends with Jackie anyway
that's a nice yeah
so that's Mortal Kombat X that's all you
need to know come on X dawn and that's
it you excited first even watch the
streams for like weeks now yeah I mean
like I I like Peter and more of a
traditional Street Fighter person like
if MK didn't have a block button I think
I would like it 10 times more but it's
harder for me to coming from a fighter
backgrounds like I mean used to holding
back yeah so having like a block button
it makes it like another it's like
another thought process right and like
especially like Mortal Kombat 3 when
they add a run I was like well [ __ ] I'm
screwed because I played pad back then
so it's just like this is making it way
worse but I mean like the game looks
good
I think the fatalities are cool like
even though maybe they're not needed in
Peter's opinion but I think they're cool
yeah that's right I called it I'm glad
they're I just don't care so much I
think they're cool and yeah let's clean
it looks it looks like he said faster
the con was you know they're longer so
we'll see cool yeah 14th at 2015 send a
couple of weeks
so it won't be too long until we all get
to play Mortal Kombat X ourselves gonna
give it to you let's gonna give it to
you